we are continuing it's my pleasure to
introduce Pacey from us see personally
[Music]
insufficiently 45 minutes I'll give you
a 5 1 0 thanks so much Steve again my
name is ping and I'm assistant professor
at the University of Southern California
I'm very excited today to attend this
workshop to share about my research and
also to learn from all of you and the
paper I'm presenting today is joint work
with it hierarchy mark Braverman and
yashka Nuria so let me begin by parsing
the title the question we're thinking
about is how to help a two-sided
matching market reach a good outcome
despite the fact that learning about
one's own preferences and communicating
that to the market is costly so for
example my home department in data
science and operations is hiring to open
rank tenure-track faculty this year and
and it is very costly for an applicant
to fill out this long application and
get the reference letters it also takes
us a lot of time to read through all the
applications and we only have a few
slots for on-campus interviews so it's
quite likely that because of the limited
capacity to learn our preferences and
communicate that to the market we might
not be able to get matched to the most
suitable candidate who is also willing
to come and so at a high level this
paper is trying to make markets such as
the academic job market clear more
quickly and the two prescriptions we
give to help this problem are
informative signalling and match
recommendations informative signaling is
about designing the message space of
what agents can communicate and match
recommendations is about encouraging
certain agents
to reach out to certain others or
discouraging certain interactions so
here is the outline of my talk I'll
first talk more about the motivation the
papers contribution and relationship to
related work and then I'll talk about
two sets of results in two sets of
theoretical models that are related so
first again the broader research agenda
we're trying to address is to facilitate
matchmaking in two-sided markets and the
problem that we are dealing with called
congestion is when the market cannot
process or communicate information
quickly enough to reach a good outcome
and this has empirically been
demonstrated to be a serious problem in
many markets and addressing this can
help improve the welfare of the
participants and also help the platform
be competitive so to address this
research agenda there's a series of
steps so we need to document what are
the current inefficiencies a theoretical
understanding of what is possible and
based on the above try to come up with
implementable prescriptions and
hopefully test them in field experiments
so this is a long research agenda and
today will only focus on this
theoretical part so the model that I
will present has some distance from
actual markets like the academic job
market but in at the end of the talk
I'll talk about some qualitative
insights that are closer to real markets
so how do we define market efficiency so
in this in this paper our definition is
no congestion outcome using the minimal
amount of communication and information
overhead and here are no congestion
outcome is a stable matching which is
the market equilibrium when everyone
knows their entire preferences and can
communicate as much as they want so let
me just review what a stable matching is
so suppose we have two candidates going
for two academic position
and alice is suitable for both UCLA and
USC but she prefers USC clearly and and
Bob is only suitable for the USC
position and USC prefers Alice over Bob
then in this simple market the only
stable matching is the blue one that
matches Alice to USC and these UCLA and
Bob are matched the reason is under any
other matching Alice and USC would like
to deviate because they prefer each
other over the other people in a small
example like this it's easy to find the
stable matching but you can imagine when
the market is large it it's it may be
hard for Alice to not to know that USC
is her favorite school out of all the
places she can get into and equally it
may be hard for USC to determine that
Alice is the best candidate given all
the people who will actually want to
come because whether Alice can get into
another school or whether another
candidate will come to USC depends on
their options and they may be waiting to
hear back from other candidates and
other schools so it's possibly hard to
find a stable matching this may be too
hard to ask for in fact there is this
priest previous impossibility result
first you to Ilya Segal and later
improved by control ski at all which is
as follows so there exists a
distribution of preferences so some
two-sided matching markets in which any
way of finding a stable matching with
high probability requires a lot of
communication so here and it's the
number of agents in this market and just
to give a background for everyone to
communicate their entire preference
ranking over the entire market requires
n log n bits so asymptotically speaking
this is just log in from communicating
your entire preferences which so one way
of interpreting this result is that
congestion is the problem to stay
there's nothing you can do about it in a
large Mart Mackie
market there's no way to find a stable
matching in such markets however when we
read the proof of this result you find
that it requires this pathologically
correlated preferences in which if I
like someone most likely they will not
like me
so it's anti-correlated preferences and
that makes it so that it's very hard
just to identify whether two people
mutually liked each other and the
contribution in this paper that I'm
presenting to you is that when we have
more natural restrictions on preferences
which I will describe make precise in a
few slides
it is possible indeed to find a stable
matching with high probability without
too much communication agents don't need
to learn their entire preference ranking
and also people have good incentives to
follow the policy and also this is the
theoretical result we can learn from the
protocol that we produce some insights
about what kind of signals are helpful
so this market design that can be
motivated from this and now let me talk
a little bit about the related work so
rather than seeing is a early paper that
documents this problem of congestion in
matching markets and they show how in
many centralized labor markets because
of congestion people act earlier and
earlier and earlier and the market
unravels one solution to this is to come
up with a centralized matching
mechanisms like what they do for the
medical residency match however even
there that doesn't solve the problem
because we still it the market is still
congested in the sense of you need to
actually interview at at the place you
want to work out and interviews are
limited so congestion can still be a
problem even in centralized matching
markets running a stable mechanism
more recently andre Fradkin found that
in air B&B at a certain point
time many requests get turned down
simply because the room is unavailable
and and once Airbnb started better
tracking availability information that
simple intervention improved the welfare
of the system in terms of the match
rates significantly and John Horton also
founds similarly that if you in up work
if you allow people to signal their
capacity that can help improve market
efficiency and but the empirical
literature left out the question
besides these simple interventions that
we can think of how much more room is
there to make the market more efficient
in terms of theoretical papers previous
papers in signaling emerging markets as
well as search and matching all assumed
some kind of a signaling mechanism or a
way in which a game in which people
participate in matches are formed and in
contrast to that our approach in this
paper is coming from this computational
communication complexity literature in
computer science in which the balance
that we produce are based on information
theory
so not dependent on any particular
signaling mechanism or any particular
way of mass formation and there's also
other models in which people learn about
their preferences differently one of
course related papers by Nikko and Irene
and and Jacob and Brendan and I'll talk
in two slides about our model of
preference learning and finally our
papers builds on the literature on
communication complexity in computer
science as well as the models of large
two-sided matching markets so now I'm
going to talk about the first model
which I call separable markets so we
need some kinds of restrictions on the
market in order to avoid the
impossibility results and and but
hopefully
I'll show the assumptions are mild and
then we can see that the previous linear
lower bound on communication vastly
reduces and we can come up with an
efficient way of forming stable
matchings which I call communication
efficient deferred acceptance so now
this is the model in one slide so I'm
gonna go through this slide fairly
slowly and so what we mean by separable
markets is there's a one-to-one match
matching markets with non-transferable
utility with workers and firms for
workers we don't have any assumptions on
their preferences they can be arbitrary
and for the firm's their utilities are
additively separable into two terms a
public school and a private school
that's why we call separable market for
this additive separate bility on one
side of the market the public scores
corresponds to the observable
characteristics of worker I and firm J
and the private school corresponds to
the unobserved idiosyncratic components
notice how the public scores depend can
depend on the IJ pair so this is a very
flexible model that embeds almost all
discrete choice models used by empirical
researchers and one assumption to make
this model not in bad general
preferences is that this epsilon term
the private schools are sufficiently
important relative to the public schools
and mathematically speaking we basically
we assume that the private schools the
tale is at least as heavy as a district
as an exponential distribution so the
hazard rate is at least one is at most
one and also the range of the public
schools is bounded by some poly
logarithmic function of the market size
that's to force this turn to be
sufficiently large relative to this term
and now notice that no one actually
knows they're the workers don't know
their own preferences and they firms
don't know their private schools up
front but every agent needs to learn
about their own preferences
by using this choice function query
which means given a set is there any
person among this set that I prefer over
being unmatched and if so who is my
favorite one so this is perhaps the
weakest point of our model because one
could argue that finding my best partner
out of a set of a thousand candidates
should should not just take one choice
function query however this is needed
for the analysis and also it may be more
justifiable in these digital platforms
in which you can easily search over
using some criteria and find the best
partner out of a certain set using
filters and ranking but given this is
our assumption on how people learn their
preferences matchings are happening
based on this communication protocol
which is this precise way to formulate
communication you can think of this as
there's a whiteboard that people can
post on people can only communicate
using the whiteboard and everyone agree
what will happen based on the history of
what is written on the whiteboard who
should write next and what should they
write and what does that mean so that's
a communication protocol and a matching
protocol is a communication protocol
that produces stable matching with high
probability meaning that as the market
size goes large we can make this
probability that we find a stable
matching to converge to one and how we
measure communication is based on the
amount of bits of information we write
on this whiteboard and preference
learning cost is how many choice
function queries agents need to make to
be able to participate Ramesh you had a
question
trace function take sets of any size yes
and then does the size of the set figure
into the communication so okay that's a
good question so you can think of this
as two models embedded in one another so
one model is the communication model
this whiteboard and so when we when
people normally talk about communication
complexity they assume people have
infinite computational power and they
can we only need to bound the amount of
communication that goes on but we don't
really care about how people figure out
what to communicate and so we build on
top of that that standard model this
additional thing that in order to play
this communication game you can only
learn about your preferences using
Oracle's of this size so to answer your
question specifically yes yes these two
are separate so I can do all the
preference learning I want and that
counts only towards the preference
learning cost but whatever information I
communicate as a result of what I
learned about myself that gets
calculated in the communication cost so
these are sort of orthogonal ways of
counting cost however in order to come
up with useful communication you
probably have to do some preference
learning otherwise you're just
communicating random things does that
make sense
yes get an answer to one of these
queries
you learn stuff about other elements of
that set right yes yes so so when you
get an answer to the query you learn
about so your preferences you learn that
this yu ji is the so for firms you
learned that you ji is the highest among
all the other eyes in this set and for
workers you know that that you know that
that firm is your favorite one so you do
learn a little bit about the other
things that's correct you don't learn
the valley
you only know that that is the maximum
among all the other things but but you
do know the AJ is you never observe the
actual value you only know it's the max
any other question yes oh that's a good
question it's questions about incentives
so for for the majority of the talk
let's assume everyone follows my
protocol so people are acting as I
desire and then I'm gonna prove that
they don't have any incentive to deviate
from that but for now let's assume that
they follow any other question yes
okay so that was a little abstract let's
consider an example of a matching
protocol this is the KO Sharpie deferred
acceptance algorithm the worker
proposing version so this is the most
standard algorithm for finding a stable
matching and then we'll see that this
algorithm has a high cost as met as
measured by the metrics I just defined
so as a review how this algorithm works
is we pick an unmatched worker and that
worker applies to their favorite firm
that they have not applied to and this
they can figure out using one choice
function query and then that firm
compares this applicant to possibly
being our matched or if the firm is
previously accepted another worker and
then the firm will pick the
out of these keeps the one the firm
likes rejects the other and in the reach
the algorithm terminates when every
worker is either mashed or has been
rejected from all the places they prefer
over being unmatched and based in using
this algorithm based on the result by
each hierarchy ashkani and Jacob lash
though if you consider this example of a
separable market in which preferences
are just iid and there's just one more
worker than firm then their analysis
implies that this algorithm does poorly
in terms of communication and preference
learning so there's linear amount of
communication and an almost linear
amount of preference learning and this
is the same as the impossibility result
previously and the intuition here is the
company excessive competition when you
have one extra worker makes it so that
there's a lot of rejections and the good
thing to do in this market is actually
to let the firm's propose rather than
the workers propose so now the question
is is there a market a separable market
in which no algorithm can do very well
and here is an example let's just take
to a random market with n workers and in
firms everything iid the catch is that
it's a sparse market which means that
each agent will only like someone else
with probability 1 over square root of n
so that means if we pick an arbitrary
pair of firm and workers the chance that
they will mutually find each other
acceptable is 1 over n and that means
that this market it will be very sparse
in terms of the mutually acceptable
pairs and so the intuition is trying to
find these mutually acceptable pairs
it's like finding needles in a haystack
it's very hard and standard arguments
use based on communication complexity
based on this disjoint is reduction to
the disjoint is
problem can show that square root and
communication is necessary in this
problem and so we cannot do better than
square root end for separable markets
the question is can we achieve this
lower bound and and the main result of
this paper is that we can and I'm going
to describe the algorithm that does it
next so let me talk about the main idea
so in the end we want to discourage
people who shouldn't apply from applying
and so we wanted this discouraged
workers who have a low utility who
wouldn't have gotten in anyway if they
applied why waste your own time and
waste the firm's time from applying and
so if someone has a low utility the firm
has a low utility for this person that
means that both the public school and
the private school has to be low so the
main idea is this if firms can solicit
workers who have high private school and
tell them to come apply then the firm
can set a threshold on the public
schools saying unless I solicited an
application from you you need at least a
certain qualification requirement on
your public school in order to qualify
yes so the reason is the first one will
get the people with the high excellence
and the second one will get the people
with high ace and if you neither have
high epsilon or high ace that means you
shouldn't apply that's the basic idea
any question here yes the firm setting
the AJ the ZJ before or after knowing
the realization on JIS so yes this is a
good question I'm gonna address this in
the next slide so this is the the
zooming out a large idea about the
details of the protocol is here this is
the communication efficient deferred
acceptance
so these qualification requirements are
done in an adaptive fashion so first we
said them to be very low everyone can
apply this means the lowest possible
public school and in the first step all
firms signal people they like
idiosyncratically they have a high
private score for however since firms
don't observe the private scores so one
way to accomplish that using choice
function queries is we can pocket
workers based on their public scores and
out of these are like the people who
look bad on paper these are the people
who look maybe somewhat better on paper
these are the people who look best on
paper and from each pin we select the
top 3 square root ends so a certain
number of my favourite workers in this
bin and that will pick out from each pin
the people who have the highest private
scores because out of people who look
the same on paper the people I like are
the ones with the good private scores
and after firms I'll send these signals
now we run the worker proposing deferred
acceptance with one change which is that
workers are only to apply if they either
received a signal in first round or they
have a high enough public score and if
the if these requirements never change
then this is basically the worker
proposing deferred acceptance and what
makes this communication efficient is
that firms update their qualification
requirements once they every time they
receive a sufficiently sufficient high
number of newly qualified applicants so
the idea is if I see a lot of
applications from people who look good
on paper because the the private scores
are IID one of these applications are
probably pretty good
so after this number of applications
with high probability I can increase my
bar yes and the reason why this protocol
works is that it
we can prove a replicates the original
worker proposing deferred acceptance
with high probability and and basically
these zj's doesn't increase with with
high probability no one who would have
gotten accepted would have been
disallowed from applying
yes any questions on on this one again
yes yes so this is by the choice
function query so so I'm gonna find my
top one and then I will find my top one
among the rest
etc yes everything here can be done
using knowledge only of the public
scores and choice function queries any
other question if you could observe the
private schools you could make this
first part you can make this first part
simpler and then yes yes but but this
part you still need some way to increase
these so this is sufficiently simple you
might be able to reduce these constants
and log factors but so observing the
Epsilon's will help simplify step one
but not step two that I know of
yes yes possibly some log factor any
other question yes so the probabilities
of this protocol is that it yields a
stable matching with high probability
and it achieves the the lower bound the
square root n except I'm hiding poly
logarithmic factors of n inside this
star and also back to the question over
here about incentives so deferred
acceptance is not incentive compatible
for anyone to begin with but we can show
that this communication efficient
version of da is with high probability
as incentive compatible SDA in the sense
that whatever incentive properties we
had with deferred acceptance we have it
here and so in particular it means that
if the market is such that there is a
unique stable matching which has been
demonstrated empirically to be
approximately true and there's
theoretical papers that motivated then
it will be an epsilon equilibrium for
everyone to follow this so that's the
and the three insights we get from here
are as follows so first we want to help
agents estimate their chance of getting
someone so that's done with this
qualification requirements that's
updating and using the public scores
second we want both side of the market
to signal interest that's done by firms
applying workers applying and firms also
doing the preference course we it's
crucial to have both sides being able to
initiate and finally we want to
discourage or prevent these hopeless
applications which is done by only
allowing workers who either was
solicited or has looked really good on
paper to apply but not people who are
unsolicited and looked bad on paper yes
Ramesh
like if you look at number two and you
contrast that with what you were talking
about yesterday yesterday essentially is
that you there are regimes in which it's
best folding one side of the market so
that's a very good question I will
actually talk about this question in
about three or four slides great yes so
so this is the concludes the first part
with the separable markets there's some
disadvantages to see that which I would
talk about now and motivates another
model with another simpler model with a
simpler protocol that addresses Ramesh's
question of what happens whether we
should allow two sides to two signal yes
so the the limitation with sida is that
applications are sequential and also
firms need to be broadcasting need to be
publicly proclaiming their zi j's to
their qualification requirement to
everyone and that could be a problem
because of a worker doesn't know how to
whether to apply before knowing the
qualification requirements and the
qualification requirements depends on
other workers applications so there's
still some congestion that's going on
because of this sequential nature of
this mechanism so it's desirable to come
up with what is called a two round
protocol in which everyone does all
their signaling simultaneously and based
on one round of signals make up their
mind on whom they like and send it to
say a third party to run a stable
matching mechanism so you can think
about this as the medical match everyone
interviews was send signals and then
based on that people participate in the
in the medical match with a short
ranking of whom they prefer so that's
the two round protocol however it's
impossible to to find the two round
protocol for all separable markets and
here's an example why so there's
horizontal heterogeneity so
two type of workers - type of firms
think of these as there's n plus-1 PhD
students who want to be a research
faculty and n of them who want to just
teach college classes however there's
few number of research oriented
positions and more teaching positions
and in any stable matching there will be
one unlucky research candidate who will
be who has to match with one of these
unfilled teaching positions and a priori
it's really unclear which of these edges
is going to be because the identity of
this unlucky person really depends on
the Preferences of of these positions
and the identity of this position
depends on the preferences of these
candidates and so in a two-round
protocol in order to reach a stable
matching with high probability everyone
here needs to communicate signal
everyone here and that's too much and
and so horizontal heterogeneity makes
this impossible so in practice this
motivates having maybe a after market
after the main market in which these
match so an open question is how many
rounds do you need in general but
staying with two rounds we can only hope
for some positive results if we allow
some more structure for example vertical
heterogeneity so in this what we call
tiered random markets this second model
that I'm talking about so agents are
partitioned into tiers that everyone
knows about so these are the pop the
star PhD candidates these are the next
year who have maybe fewer publications
these are the people who don't have
publications and here are the Tier one
schools tier two schools etcetera we
assume that people always prefer the
better tiers but we think each tier is
completely random how they prefer and
also everyone finds every one else
acceptable that's the assumption it's
also called a block correlated
preferences in previous papers
so the question here back to a machinist
question is who should signal who who
should initiate contact and so in next
three lies I'm gonna give three examples
to illustrate what's going on here
in the first example let's assume
there's one tier of each so this is just
an unbalanced iid market and there's one
there's fewer firms than workers and the
result that goes back to Patel is that
if you allow firms to do the firm
proposing deferred acceptance algorithm
with high probability every firm will be
matched to one of their top log square
and candidates this implies that in this
market let's just let the firm's
proposed and then they just signal every
firm signal their top lakhs log Square
and candidates and with high probability
the subgraph induced by these these
contacts will contain a stable matching
yes
so now let's complicate this picture a
little bit let's assume there's two
tiers of workers so this goes back a
little bit to implements this question
because if we look at the top workers
they are in a better position than the
firms because if we forget them they are
on the short side however if you look at
the firms that are left over after the
top workers have picked they are in a
better position than the bottom workers
so here what you want to do is to have
the top workers apply to a signal and
then have the firm signal to the bottom
workers and you can show that this is an
efficient two round protocol and as a
third example let's consider workers are
IID in the sense they're homogeneous
ex-ante and firms are vertically ranked
meaning that there's each tier just
contains one firm so in this simple
example those unique stable matching is
induced by Co dictatorship by the firm's
the first firm picks the second firm
takes the best remaining but since
there's iid preferences for
workers most likely the second form is
not going to collide with the first form
so in fact you can show efficient to run
protocol is in which the je ferme the
chase ranked firmed up high signals
workers and and in this ratio and over n
minus J plus one that's the inverse of
the proportion of workers who are not
matched to better ranked firms so
basically they they care to pick their
favorite person except if they collided
with someone above them and if they send
this many signals that cover the case in
which they collide and you can show that
these sum up two on average is going to
be log square n number of signals and so
in the general case for general cheered
random markets the protocol works as
follows it's the aggregation of the
ideas previously but the proof is more
complicated essentially each each agent
will signal people in what is called the
target here what is the target here
these are the people on the other side
who is just slightly in a worse position
than I am so the end point the bottom
here is slightly lower so the target
here if these people are the firm's here
the target here of these firms are the
workers here everyone just signals
slightly below them and the amount a
signal has it's log square n divided by
this row n and this this row I is
similar to the example with the serial
dictatorship this is to prevent this is
the proportion of partners that are not
taken by better rank people so combining
all these ideas we get this protocol
which has the good properties as the
seeder protocol the bounds get much
better in this in this market and also
it's a two-round protocol in which
everyone does their signalling at the
same time and all communication are
between pairs of agent rather than
broadcasting to the whole market the
insides are the same as before
basically we estimate help agents
estimate their chances using this tier
structure we allow both sides of the
market to signal and we only allow
people to signal down but not go up so
now with the last few minutes I'm going
to talk about practically how would one
implement this what does it mean so how
to help agents estimate their chances so
for cases like university admission
there's in which there's a threshold
cutoff on the score of an applicant
people can publish forecasts of these
which is done in universities I believe
in Israel Iran and other countries also
for digital platforms you can imagine
these up work or other platforms using
their data to create some kind of a
prediction tool of whether a prospective
partner will reciprocate interest what's
my chance of getting someone and this
tool can get better if we collect better
data so for example Ramesh and Chun
Gordon they work with up work in which
to allow firms to signal the quality am
i looking for high quality workers and
willing to pay more or I'm just willing
to get someone to get the job done so
making the Preferences that firms more
expressive allows them to allows agents
to better predict okay now I see this
employers hiring they want quality
people okay am i a good match or not it
so making things more expressive helps
the market to sort more efficiently and
we can also maybe use the idea in sida
in which we look at how many
applications the firm already is getting
in real time and if a firm is getting a
lot of good applicants we can say this
is a hard firm like what happens on
Zillow with a hot property and then
maybe use this to improve the prediction
tool these are ideas about number one so
number two how do we actually allow both
sides of the market to signal so for the
academic job market it would be helpful
if there is some comprehensible and
searchable registry of all potential
candidates this year so for example the
in the operations market there are some
attempts to make this independent
website in which everyone tries to
register that's an ongoing effort and in
the economics job market departments
keep their list of their top people so
in some sense in the economics market
schools can potentially initiate contact
as well without the person actually
applying and this will help my
department for example we're trying to
recruit to positions that's very hard
especially if it's open bank positions
so having some way we can target
recruitment will be helpful but but for
large online platforms like it like
employment platform it it's hard for
workers for firms to signal individual
workers because there's too many of them
so you can't really the only way to help
firms to initiate contact is if we
collect good information on the workers
and design some way for firms to say I'm
gonna want to signal all workers who
have this amount of experience who have
done X and X and Y to say apply and it's
important to make sure that the number
of people who match the filters is
sufficiently small so that these signals
are informative but this is a way in
which without knowing identity of
individual workers firms can signal to
specific people and finally how to
prevent hopeless applications I already
talked about how we can track
availabilities of the other people but
we can also restrict who will contact
so this goes back to Josh's paper he
talked about yesterday for example in
the dating app bumble the women are the
ones who have to initiate contact and
typically women on dating apps are on
the short side of the market so it makes
sense for them to initiate rather than
the other way so it's not that we always
want both sides to to be initiating
contact because again enough three
examples I give in the first example we
only want the short side two to initiate
and restrict the other side so match
recommendation is both about
recommending and also preventing certain
contacts from forming which are bad
equilibria and finally we want to when
when we're doing a search tool to rank
people we we shouldn't be training the
algorithm to only rank people based on
my own preferences but also based on
whether that person will actually
reciprocate so yes and that will be more
useful for helping the market coverage
and so that concludes my talk and I'm
happy to talk more offline thank you
[Applause]